thank you very much for being here today
and especially given that it's a warm
and sunny Saturday London which is like
really where and so my talk today would
be about building a classifier to
distinguish between train and car
journeys using telematics data so about
myself and so I studied applied
mathematics and statistics at University
which I believe makes me more of a type
a data scientist which is radical these
days my first experience was actually in
finance working as an analyst ingested
management industry but I ended up
escaping the city at the end of 2013 as
I was very curious to see what was
happening in the tech sector in London I
joined a halo and at the beginning of
2014 where the chance to meet as Tiffin
and Linda and later young with one of
the organizer and that's the reason why
I am here today because I felt in der
and famous that will be great for took a
trap and I join my droid solutions at
the beginning of this year in February
and I've been focusing on telematics
data and so I would like to start by
giving a short introduction on madrea
solution so you can understand better
the type of data that the company
collects and the products that are
created using this data and so my drive
is like centered around data science and
software engineering and I'm quite lucky
to be working with like a really big
thing given the size of the company
which is at the moment 36 people so
working with me on data science and we
have blanket days and Sophie we also
very lucky to have two big design
engineers and which are like really
coveted this time Mary Steinberg done
and also Masha will spend a lot of time
working on this project before me and
was currently in Croatia finishing a
master thesis that's why she cannot be
here with me today and so my drive
solutions is a london-based company
founded 2010 it got acquired last summer
by generally which is one of the leading
insurance group in the world so
generally is currently serving more than
like 65 million customers in 60
countries so my drive is now deploying
its technology in general is different
markets and and basically the core
product of my drive at the moment is a
driver profiling but the company is also
looking to apply its competences to
health and smart home solutions
and so my drive provides end-to-end
telematic solutions which means that we
use a variety of device to capture
drivers data so it could just be a
mobile application it could also be an
onboard device or a professionally
installed device in the car and so we
ensure that the data collection is as
accurate as possible and we also contact
EULA contextualize the data against the
road topography because it's not the
same driving of course in an urban area
than on a highway in the middle of the
countryside and so this is just like a
small example of the type of data will
be capturing so and we will be lecturing
some driving events such as like speed
or breaking add junctions extracting
from junctions and also the road context
around this event oops
and so this is like a brief overview of
the pipeline so we start by capturing
second-by-second and GPS data from
drivers the data is then sent to s3 and
we have an ETL geocoding and matching
workers that are clean and ensure that
the data is accurately contextualized we
then have another worker that identifies
the events we are interested in such as
speed braking and acceleration the data
is then aggregated so like the usual
period we're using to calculate drivers
course is a 90-day period and the
driver's car is then sent to the
relevant party in transcriptionally so
in terms of the outputs on the end
customer site and so drivers get two key
outputs like the first one is that they
can look back at the trip history and
for each trip they can see like how they
perform like what mistakes they made and
my drive work quite closely with raspa
which is a society that is like focusing
on preventing accidents to make sure
that we provide the most efficient
safety safety trips to ensure that we
prevent as many accidents as possible on
the roads and the SAG on output is the
drivers call so a drivers can see how to
have perform
overall historically and sorry and they
can see if they're like meeting some
progresses or if at some time and they
started like being a bit less attention
and we are breaking down the score in
like four subscores so driver can really
learn from that process and so I will
now introduce the new data challenge
because you might wonder why do we need
a classifier to distinguish between
train and car journeys um well as I
mentioned in some regions we are using a
mobile phone application to capture the
data and this is great because it has an
auto start feature which means that when
the phone identifies that you are in
movement at a speed that is higher than
working then the data gets recorded
automatically and that means that my
drive gets more data and it also helps
us prevent fraud because some drivers
and if they had the choice to record
everything manually might want to hide
some trips where you know Dana rush and
they know they're going to be like
speeding and across town and but also
like the issue with this Auto Start
features is that sometime some journeys
that should not be recorded get recorded
and because the product is all around
personalization we want to make sure
that we only take into account trips
when you are the driver and let that go
this is
and because actually you get some angry
calls from like clients when you like
tell them that we're like speeding at a
crazy pace across town when they were
actually on a train to work so in terms
of like the data and the tools that have
used to tackle this challenge and the
first data set is my drives internal
trip data so we are as data scientists
were quite lucky to have access to
highly present so I'll precise second by
second data and so for each points of a
trip and we get at a minimum the trip ID
the latitude longitude the times than
the speed recorded by the device and
some measures that will help us assess
the quality of the data such as the
number of satellites and you can see
that for this car journey and dew points
are like nicely as snaps along the roads
and you can see where like the driver
was speeding a little bit or like
breaking before Junction and the second
that I said is actually coming from a
year which is all map providers and we
get different like shape files with some
information about the regions in which
we operate and so we get the road links
but we also get the rails and
interestingly for this project train
stations and the commuter rail stations
so I transform like those shape files
into a table with the station name the
type of station
the latitude and longitudes and merge it
with the trip data and so in terms of
like the tools and I use cookies that's
what you saw on the previous slide to
easily explore a different shape size
provided by here because of my
background I must admit that I'm mostly
our users so I use our with like our
studio to do some exploratory data
analysis and some visualizations and
also to build an initial model so i used
deep litter and leaflets on the
visualization sides and carrots to train
and test the model i also took advantage
of a library called egg geosphere and
that allows you to calculate and
variables just like the perimeter of a
trip or like the shortest distance
between star points under endpoints of a
trip and at the end of the of the talk
and i will show briefly how i
implemented a DS models in any lip and
i've also used spark SQL to extract the
features i was interested in because as
I'm working with like points data which
are like starred in s free as sparks is
really making my life easier
and so let's start looking at the data
and the different like variables that
are interesting for this type of project
so as i mentioned that i use spark and
the peanut book to extract and compute
the different features we have used AWS
and the zeppelin netbook is nicely
integrated is really easy for engineers
when they start a cluster to also
launched and as if in a book and so as
you can see i can load some files that
are like started in s3 in that case as I
practice files and transform them into a
data frame and you can use then spark
just like SQL queries to create some new
data frames from those original that I
frame so if you come from an analyst
background this is more this is a bit
easier than jumping straight to scalar
an RDD and also like a nice feature of
the Zeppelin in World Books is that
using SQL queries you can create some
simple visit visualizations to help you
understand the data along the way and so
when you think about what differentiates
train journeys from car journeys and the
first feature that might come to mind is
X train station because it's quite
obvious like is sure like on a trend you
like cross a number of station which is
not necessarily the case and for cars
and
and when you plot the distributions and
for the data set I was working at you
can see that indeed the median number of
stations for train journeys is 5 and 0
for car journeys so at the very
beginning when I start this project I
thought it would be easy i would just
look at train stations and that's for
like given get me my train trips however
when i started like looking at the false
positive I discovered that even outside
the cities rels and roads can run really
close to each other and sometimes even
like overlaps so you can select the red
dots I like the one second data of a car
trips a longer road and this is like
crossing the rail and also there your
sentation center that we get Alex
sometimes on the roadside there rather
than being on the rail side which means
that the cars could be actually that
closer to the station centers than the
trains so we need to have more
information and a very interesting
variable is the percentage of points
snapped to roads when my dr processes
the data we make sure that they're the
GPS points are correct early correctly
contextualize and so we match them to
the closest road length and so if you
have like a train journey and you look
at Sarah Cardoni and you look at the
process data you'll see that that like
nicely aligned along the roads and I
already look at a train journey you'll
have some big gaps and you only get snap
points when the rails are like close to
a
wood and so it should take like the
ratio of the number of points that two
roads over the number of the route data
points sort of libraries very simple and
you can see that for train the medians
like fifty percent and it's much higher
for cars so sometimes we have that data
big for like our trips because of the
phone order the coverage in an area
another interesting variable is a path
efficiency and so to give you an
intuition of what path efficiency is
when you plot a car journey next to a
train journey you can see that the car
journey it's much more rigo's much more
and you can even lacks but visually like
things like roundabouts or you know like
short turns inner cities for train and
like those journeys are like much more
direct you have is almost like no
wiggling going on so in order to capture
dots and so I use the gel just for
library in our and I took the ratio of
the shortest distance between the start
point and the end point of the trip over
the total perimeter for the trip
including like all the wiggles and again
when you plot the distribution you can
see that the median path efficiency for
train and is eighty-three percent and
sixty-six percent are for cars
and the speed is also an interesting
variable and so when you plot like the
speeds for train trip it's nice because
you can see and then when the train is
like in the urban area and it goes quite
like slowly under stations are quite
close to each other however when it's
it's out in a more kind of suburban zone
and the speed increases between stations
and then decreases again as the train
gets closer to station and if you
actually it's quite nice when you plot
the speed versus time you can see those
like big variation for train journeys
why like cars the variation will be like
much smaller and close to each other
because of all the breaking that you
have to do because I've like red lights
gets crossing the streets whatever can
happen in a in a car journey and so the
median standard deviation for train trip
is higher than for car trip and so we
considered also like some other
variables coming from like the events we
are collecting and such as the breaking
I've read breaking some deviation I'm
saving for acceleration and the distance
of the points to dr. closest like
worldlings but after some initial
analysis actually the free variables
that were the most like significant and
were helping the classifier the most
were the percentage of points snap to
rose to transition portrait and path
efficiencies
sorry it's a bit small but as you can
see those variables are very little like
the correlation between each other and
cool so let's now start looking at the
models and so the first approach I use
is actually a simple like logistic
regression using like those free
variables and using cross-validation as
parts and then focus radiation as part
of the carrots package and so sorry yes
so the model is classifying train
journeys versus that car journeys so we
want to detect for each driver its train
journey so we can like remove them from
like the scoring pipeline to ensure that
the final score only like reflex is
driving behavior
yes that was painful and we're actually
like looking that's because we have in
production like like obvious like a an
easy approach approach as well as like
snapping the points the Rose would be
like to snap them against Darrell but
that's quite intensive but what we are
looking at like going forward to kind of
like increase the training set as we
move to like some different countries
and ensure that the general as well we
want to be like a simple like snapper to
Darrell's so like the labelling is
ultimate eyes are not manual
well because um I mean mad as I mention
like a colleague of mine I'd like
started working on distinguishing
between train and car journeys to add
like cam that I said 22 starts with and
basically I thought that as I was
getting some promisingly result I was
just going to continue with this
approach and as my initial like model
were other really like a good some good
performance I could more easily than get
more and more train journeys
and so yes just a curious if additional
model with eighty-six percent under oh
yeah under Luc and 0.9 sticks and so
this are gonna approach Oh Andrea and I
mentioned like something that's more on
the practical side of like doing data
sense in the private sector an advantage
of like this model when you're like
working like a lot of leg different like
external clients because we not only
work with generally but we also work
with other insurance providers in
countries in which generally doesn't
operate is that like logistic regression
is a bit like easier to communicate and
to have approval from the client and if
you come up you know with like a black
box where people can be a bit more
deliberative and also at the moment and
this type of model is much easier to get
implemented you know production pipeline
because we are dependent also for
engineers to get the work of data sense
team in production and I were like I
started like to explore like some
alternative type of models and like
random forests and gave some even better
like results so that's differences a
model I will keep looking at in the
futures as we get targeting data from
more and more countries and and so
as a disclaimer I don't have a lot of
experience with a pie spark and Emily
but as a team we feel that this is the
type of approach we should adopt going
for it and I know the engineers are
working to get a new data pipeline in
production so we can independently
retrain and implement models and
actually it was relatively easy to build
the model using Emily and by spark I to
do just like a few tweaking with the
model parameters to get the same result
as I got in our so the I just had to
parse the testing the training and
testing set to have labelled points and
our DD and then apply the logistic
regression and so our system is
operating in city gay right do not use
the links between these buildings until
further notice I don't want to be
responsible for the death of em I did
this room s'okay i'm almost at the end
of my talk anyway so you can run away
whenever you want insurance as well yeah
yeah actually that's why I feel like a
good partnership on it next year like
Phi Phi results and so yesterday select
small like eight weeks and I saw a lot
of people where we like programs just
that you need to remember to set the
intercept true when you're using like
the risk regression in anna lib and then
it's you know really easy to just like
applied
on the pasta sets and get your
performance metrics so if any of you had
some experience using this type of
approach I will be very interested to
hear your thoughts and because that's
really like what we're starting to
explore as a team at the moment and and
so just in time for you to run out of
the fire exits for this with this was in
a nutshell how I want to like tackle
this data challenge thank you very much
for your time do you have some add
something to share like the sort of the
code or so i will be sharing like the
slides and i think they will be
available on the website after the event
one who has or is able to appoint some
psycho then obviously we will find out
as well it just depends where I produce
associate yeah I will need to check with
I doubt that they will be able to to
share like the yeah some snippets and I
was just like some sleep that's you may
get some questions about the care a
library on the cat all right talk to
thank you very much I did I was just
wondering like the company like yours I
do understand that but there's a small
scope but do you work with cities to
help city planning so no I mean we like
the do companies free you know like open
to use some over like data sources and
we participate you're a captain
organized by a TfL looking at the data
they capture using like sensors across
the city so I think if that is also like
looking to share this data so you know i
think the the company has been quite
productive in terms of collaborations is
when we have not just somebody's running
on the train or a car on a trance you
just use their oyster yeah well you know
yeah so yeah for falafel like London and
like in cities were you have like this
type of like tracking system and when
the data is available that will be also
and very useful especially when you
start looking at bus versus cars and yes
that's another interesting that I said
to you to merge yeah more on the course
I do you find I mean anecdotally that
there are correlations between driving
behavior and claims yes so that's their
initial purpose of like also having your
digging so we were like refining and
because now that we are expanding you
know using lectra Knollys a client base
we see how that might like vary in
different countries and we refined the
model to ensure that is like a good
correlation between the score under
claims technical questions it was it the
size of the data or what was it the
major mood to spark happy a good cluster
yeah and so for the because we have to
date engineers I they set up the size i
have the cluster Fermi's I just tell
them you like the size of the data set
I'd be looking at and I i didn't use
like the biggest cluster there but still
it was it's a particular data set
because we second by second point data
for each journey so it's I couldn't do
it in in our like this are would locally
are crushed like straight away so I to
to learn to learn spark on the job to be
able to start the analysis and there's a
smart phone in case he thought about my
passenger detection it's not a problem
when somebody's not driving but they're
saying a cat yes so that's also one of
the challenges will need to tackle but
so yeah there are different ways to go
about it because you can like once you
know the driving style of someone then
you can use that to you know identify if
is driving or not but there's also some
solutions more on the UX front end side
that can be used to be prevented from
Sam data what days are people happy to
share and what are they objecting of the
other said or you not try to to share um
so I mean even if the end customers are
like happy to share that data so all
these people have like voluntarily
signed up to dislike insurance kids and
and reassures like disclose that they
will be using that data to carry the
score and to personalize the insurance
product still offered them so I would
imagine that the older people that have
signed up were like happy to share that
data on people were not happy would not
have again this telematics options I
mean of course that's going to be like
the second interesting debate and we
have to be very very careful about that
make sure people are aware of what they
data sharing especially when you start
looking at he health so two things that
might be related an option first want to
stroke French mention yesterday very
interesting technique wouldn't have the
graph Lewis is expensive is to do it
first platen cases and then look at the
badly classified of the exceptions the
one where you yeah I'm so bad at that
second question can you detect I drove
to the station and then I use
okay a single journey that has the two
elements yeah so so your first question
was so using like taking the false
positive and making sure that they can
take a new tack yes better feeding yes
yes this as a second step first use you
a few examples then do a second trophies
just sitting there it might be explained
to take me off and I again go Sal about
it yesterday yes so in so yeah we were
interested to hear more about the
technique what's up sorry yeah
absolutely we can discuss a value but
yes as so basically i'm when i first
started like you know building like a
model i had a lot of car trips that were
having many station points because they
were like on roads running alongside
like Darrell's so I made sure that at
cases as part of my training sets like
such trip to sew them the model will
like addressed for that and your second
question I just you know the places that
you have heart I'm pacifying are people
that drove to a station sir oh yes and
so about oh that's so usually what
happens and is that like like the
driving bit to the station is quite
short and then train trip is longer so
we consider like the whole trip as being
a train trip however in the future we
might want to break the trip into
different parts but that's something you
can identify we've like the speed
standard deviations because if you plot
the speed you have the first bit when
the person is driving if you know like
relax shot cycles and
like a short range and then when you
have the train you have like again like
those kind of like longer like cycles
because I did the train connects unless
you know the cars on the highway a
training table like to do go to highest
piece yeah jumps alone hmmm obviously
not ideal classroom also you know just
see where the songs drive so for because
i was using for the scoring process we
of course clean the data when we process
it a like slept with the road so we
apply another engineering team is a
playing different type of filtering like
a cannon filter so you don't have this
bumpiness and for so i was using some
process data that was already clean
thanks to the processing and for Drew
Jake gets like the variables like such
as a count of stations that was not too
much of her other problems so I could
benefit from the work of their engineers
and put a question about the resort of
obd devices versus the smartphone app so
apart from put aside the LBD can give
you like vehicle analytics and is there
any sort of do we know and which one is
a better or the sort of the use cases
around those circus they kind of you
know the smartphone can do a lot more
processing but I think I don't from the
jury might still be out so I just wanted
to keep you yes so I mean my
understanding is that people are
included increasingly looking at as
mobile application solutions because
it's a cheaper and faster and like
easier to like implement and and in
terms of the do quality so yes actually
there newer device gives you like some
better data than the older like device
at the general rule so it reconned of
like depends on what the insurer wants
to develop as a product if it wants to
have some like we really the most
precise data and the company doesn't
care about the cost and I guess they
might go with an onboard proficiently
like install device if they want
something that it's easier to distribute
and to reach like a bigger like market
share then i guess like by application
so it's often like a business question
is no question then thank you again and
then we have couple breaks